with over 500 sessions at next 2018 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see machine
learning with scikit-learn and extra
boost on Google cloud platform then stay
tuned because here's the rewind I really
enjoyed this session because it talks
about using cycle on and actually boost
in some unexpected ways from trading in
clusters for large single node virtual
machines to using managed services to do
the scaling for you this talk was packed
with demos code and great tips and
tricks plus you get to hear from David
corn 'po the creator of second learn
more to treat let's dive in second learn
and extra boost are great libraries and
unlike tensor flow they're not used for
deep learning but for a class of
problems which are very common in
businesses you may find that extra boost
or scikit-learn
can give you better results with less
effort we can view the machine learning
work flow through the simplified lens of
three stages pre-processing training and
prediction pre-processing is a stage of
machine learning in which the raw data
is made ready for the modeling this
leads us to training which is the
process in which a model is tuned to
predict a target variable from labelled
input data and finally prediction is
then that process of predicting results
for new unlabeled input there are many
challenges when it comes to
pre-processing and for unstructured data
scikit-learn can sometimes fall short
here the machine learning api's can
prove pretty helpful the photo talk
shows a couple of examples of this and
there's one in particular where the
natural language API is used to tokenize
Japanese text and this solves a problem
that's not suitable for second learns
pre-processing modules it's a really
interesting example the second stage of
the ML workflow is the training and if
you know that icon it's the Google
compute engine icon so you might be
thinking are we really gonna talk about
virtual machines in a machine learning
talk the answer is a resounding yes
nowadays virtual machines have gotten
way bigger compute engine allows you to
configure up machines with up to four
terabytes of memory
not disk memory and it's even got the
compute power to pair with it so we can
do something with that memory and on the
software side libraries like desk allow
you to paralyze your work in pandas
without needing to have a cluster of
multiple machines set up even at big
companies the large data sets being used
they end up typically being less than 14
gigabytes and even for truly large data
sets you can often just take a subset of
that data for experimentation so don't
underestimate the cost of losing out on
what David calls data agility the full
talk offers up a great resource for
helping you take advantage of this kind
of burst training with a script that
sets up a machine run your job and then
cleans it all up afterwards definitely
check that out if you're looking to try
out this mode of operating the final
portion of the talk covers cloud ml
engine if your service relies on
predictions or if you regularly need to
retrain your model on new data cloud ml
engine can help in scikit-learn and
actually boost are also now supported in
addition to tensorflow and it's for both
training and prediction so you don't
need to use different workflows for
different machine learning libraries the
full talk has a pretty slick
top-to-bottom demo of pre-processing the
data training a scikit-learn model and
then exporting that model and finally
deploying it to cloud ml engine all in
one notebook if you like this video give
it a thumbs up and I've included the
link to the full talk in the description
below and don't forget to subscribe to
the Google cloud YouTube channel for
more great content I'll see you on the
next rewind
[Music]